Now, before we continue, I would like you to think a little bit about
the implications of what we have just shown.
We have just shown that the halting problem is undecidable.
What I would like to think about for a moment here is what that means or implies,
and I would like you to select the ones that are correct.
The halting problem being undecidable, does that mean that an algorithm
that solves the halting problem would take far more than exponential time to run,
does it mean that an algorithm for this problem here for the halting problem cannot exist
or does it mean that if we gave them any specific program and are asked to solve the halting problem
that will never be possible, at least not using an algorithm.